they don't give men any tactical
advantage and I'm talking about small
things a man's not even allowed to be a
man in his own house you know in England
you will get accused of emotional abuse
I can marry a woman not lay a hand on
her I can just raise my voice to her
that's emotional abuse I can raise my
voice or her because she's going out
drinking with dudes she can go out
drinking six nights of night and week
with men and I can say what the [__] can
my wife sit down she can call the cops
call me emotionally abusive I get
arrested now now there's a court case
against me I have to go to court and
defend myself she'll divorce me take my
house I have to sell my car because
she's drinking vodka with [__] God
knows who but you know